hi I was a big fan of the first movie
um and yeah I just got an email being
like do you want to read for this movie
it didn't say anything you're like well
again
um but it was your ending monologue from
the first movie that was the what you
auditioned yes that was the audition
maybe he's for a spider person but I was
like I don't know and then I wasn't
aware of Spiderman India at all or any
of that stuff and then when I got it
they were like this is what it is and I
was like oh my God this is very exciting
I had done a bunch of the sessions and
then they called like a few months ago
and they were like hey you're feeling
like it's not culturally specific enough
so we were gonna do a little writer's
room and we want you to come and like
just ideas wow that's amazing I
grew up in India and I just know like
this character will mean so much to
people from India I've gotten like some
of the messages Dave Phil and Chris were
like just so open they were like blow it
up like what do you want to say and like
the chai tea bit all this stuff that was
so specific came out of that
session oh my God and it was the most
collaborative experience